- [Narrator] This program
is a presentation of UCTV
for educational and
noncommercial use only.
(pleasant synth music)
- Welcome to a Conversation with History.
I'm Harry Kreisler at the
Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is Dr. Lucy Shapiro,
who is director of the
Beckman Center for Molecular
and Genetic Medicine
at Stanford University, and the
Ludwig Professor of Cancer Research
in the School of Medicine there,
and a senior fellow of the
Spogli Institute for International
Studies also at Stanford.
She is the 2009 Hitchcock
Professor at UC Berkeley.
Professor Shapiro, welcome to Berkeley.
- Thank you.
- Where were you born and raised?
- I was born and raised
in Brooklyn, New York.
- Aha, and looking back how
do you think your parents
shaped your thinking about the world?
- Let's see, I'm the
daughter of immigrants,
and it was extremely
important for my generation
of immigrant children
to be very successful,
and we were a poor household,
but there was always
somehow the wherewithal
to give us piano lessons
and dancing lessons and language lessons,
and academics was extremely important.
- And was science something you picked up
at home, in high school, in college?
- No not at all.
In fact I have a very unusual background.
So music was always very
important in my household.
My mother was a piano teacher
and a public school teacher,
and my father was just always
interested in the entire world
but music was important.
And so I read music.
I played the piano
before I learned to read.
My piano lessons started
at the age of four,
and it was very much a part of my life,
but I knew that I wasn't
a very good musician.
(laughs)
And in the neighborhood in which I lived
in Brooklyn, New York the high
school I would've gone to,
mandated, I think was called
Manual Training High School
where perhaps 2% of the
population went on to college.
So this was not an option.
Clearly private schools
were not an option,
but living in New York
City is an incredible place
because there were public
special high schools that were free.
There was the Bronx
High School of Science.
There was Stuyvesant.
There was the High
School of Music and Art,
and so my parents said this is perfect.
You will try out, and there was a test
and they all assumed I would go for music,
and a year before I was to take the test
to get into Music and Art,
I decided I do not want to
play a musical instrument for
four years in high school.
And so I went to the
library and got a book.
I remember that to this day
written by Jon Gnagy on how to draw.
I said I'm gonna learn how to draw.
(laughs)
And I did, and I studied this book
and I prepared a whole portfolio.
Fortunately, fortunately
I have some talent.
Then I went off to my test
at Music and Art and got in,
and my parents were utterly
astonished to find out
that I had gotten in on painting,
and that was the beginning of my sort of
taking left hand turns everywhere.
- And the science bug, and I
guess I should put that in--
- There was no science
at that point at all.
- So when did that come to you?
- Well I went to Music and Art,
and then I went to Brooklyn College
where I was put on a new
program as a scholar,
and as this excuse me.
(coughing)
As this scholar, I didn't
have to take classes.
I could do whatever I wanted,
but I reported to people.
And during this time, I
became somewhat interested
in biology but I majored in fine arts.
I was a painter, and I also
minored in the classics.
Wrote my senior thesis on Dante,
and why he wrote in the
vernacular and not Latin.
But I was interested somewhat in science,
and then something amazing happened.
When I was--
(coughs)
Excuse me.
When I was graduating from college,
I was part of an art show and
a man named Ted Shedlovsky
at Rockefeller University
who was a physical chemist
bought one of my paintings,
and Ted had this avocation in life
of finding young people in the arts,
getting to know them,
deciding if they were smart,
and then convincing
them to go into science.
- [Harry] Gee.
- Yeah Gerry Edelman, a Nobel Prize winner
is one of us Shedlovsky kids.
There are a whole bunch
of us, and he's a mentor,
and he said what you have to do
is take a course in organic chemistry.
And I said really?
And I did, and it was an eye opener.
I absolutely loved it, and maybe
because it's the way my head works
I see things in three dimensions,
but I thought organic chemistry
was absolutely beautiful,
and this is really what I wanted to do.
- And then where did you do your PhD work?
- So at that point, Ted encouraged me
to apply for graduate programs
even though I had barely
no background to do so.
I think Rutgers was my safe school,
and they turned me down,
but I got into almost
everywhere else I applied
and I went to Albert, well it was
New York University at the time.
A year later, the whole department
moved to Albert Einstein
College of Medicine,
but I was accepted and my whole first year
in graduate school was very unusual.
- Well it sounds like you needed to take
some beginner courses to
do the preparatory work
you hadn't done in college.
- I took a lot of math,
physics, a lot of chemistry.
And I had the unusual
opportunity of taking courses
at different universities around the city.
So my mentor at that time, Tom August
and mentors and Jerry Hurwitz
a very well known biochemist,
helped me find the very
best courses in the city.
- [Harry] Oh gee!
- And so I just had incredible training,
and chemistry was really
some of the most exciting
things I had been exposed to,
but I had to learn how
to think analytically.
So courses in physics
and quantum mechanics
and statistical mechanics
were really very important
and it was the first time in my life
where I had to really work hard
to, you know I remember doing problem sets
morning, noon, and night, but I did learn.
And while this was going on
I was actually working in a laboratory.
- So hands on experience?
- Absolutely.
- Yeah.
So this raises an interesting
question 'cause you,
we'll talk about your research in a minute
but you're on the cutting
edge of major breakthroughs
in developmental biology and genetics
as you studied bacteria,
and I think students in our audience
would be interested in what it takes,
the skill base involved in what you do.
You've already given us a hint of that,
but talk a little about that, I mean--
- Well let me come at
it in a different angle.
- [Harry] Okay.
- The fact that I went from
fine arts and the classics
to learning quantitative
approaches to science
sort of gave me license to
try to do different things,
and gave me the belief
that I could do anything
that I wanted to do.
So I was never on a track.
And when I realized that I had to learn
how to think quantitatively
and analytically,
and it was hard work,
then I knew I could approach
any scientific question
I wanted to approach
whether it was in physics or chemistry
or biology it didn't matter,
but I was interested in the living world.
- Now that raises an interesting question
'cause it's scientists
who appreciated your art
and directed you into science
and then you were in music.
Is there a landscape of the
mind, let me say it this way,
in music and art that in addition
to building self-confidence in you
that you could do anything,
talk a little about that.
Are these worlds not as different
as we might think they are?
- Oh I don't think they are really.
I think what we're dealing
with is creativity,
and the ability or the desire
to think differently.
And I think that's critical.
And what I found in writing about Dante
and trying to understand what he did
is I could get bits and pieces
of anecdotal information
and try to make a logical construct,
but once I was working
in the science domain
there was a lot more hard data,
and I could take this hard
data and what I like to say
is build stories, build
supposements, build ways of thinking
and then try very hard to disprove
what I think I'm purporting to be true.
And that's the key of
doing really good science.
Get your theory, get your
hypothesis, get your idea.
Collect data of course to support it,
but then try very hard to find
out if you can knock it down,
and you know it's like a detective story.
You collect clues, and I think that
that kind of approach to anything,
whether it's worrying about Dante's opus
or worrying about the bacterial cell cycle
is what I ultimately studied
is an extremely valuable
and not unusual way
that scientists approach what they do.
- And so in this creative
process you were really turning
what might be self doubt into a tool
to sharpen your hypothesis
and your assertions.
- That's right, that's correct.
- And I guess that it was in retrospect
it turns out to be a real virtue
that you weren't tracked
early in the sciences.
- Yes and I think it's
really fairly unusual.
Frequently now we see people
coming from the science,
physics and chemistry
and going into biology
'cause that's pretty exciting right now.
Rarely do you see it the other way.
Do you see people from
humanities going into science,
and that's a pity because
certainly it can be done
and it's easier to do it in the
United States than in Europe
where the education is much
more channeled, or in Asia.
You just don't see this
kind of freedom to change,
but I think it's extremely important
that people keep an open mind
about what they might want to do
or how they might want to do it,
and there are no rules and regulations.
You can learn how to think differently
at any stage in your life,
and it also gave me the freedom
at every stage of my scientific career
to learn a different kind of science,
and because of that I could apply
many many different ways of thinking.
Many different disciplines
to one question.
And I was very fortunate in
that after I finished my PhD
which was in molecular biology in which
I discovered a new RNA
dependent RNA polymerase,
and I was really trained as a biochemist
when I did a short post
doc for only six months
and then was offered an
assistant professorship
back in the department that
I had gotten my PhD in,
and the chair at the time said
why don't you take three months
and think about what you want to work on?
This hardly ever happens anymore.
Usually you're really tracked in.
People do three years, four
years of post doctoral work.
Well I didn't do that.
And that three months
of thinking and reading
was just incredible, and I
had decided at that point
that if I was going to spend my life
working on a scientific problem,
it had to be something
I was passionate about.
And it seemed to me at that time
that I wanted to understand
what it meant to be a living thing,
and I tried to find the
simplest cell I could study,
which turned out to be a bacterial cell,
and study that cell as if
I were a systems engineer.
Taking it apart in all of its parameters
and then putting it back together again.
Of course I'm speaking metaphorically,
but we've been able to in fact
do it much more than metaphorically.
And understand how a living entity,
all the things it does to go
from one cell to two cells
and be alive is completely integrated.
It's like an absolutely beautiful machine,
and so I dedicated my
life to figuring this out.
- And let's talk a
little about that because
in your work, and in
your lecture yesterday
you showed us a DNA and a bacteria,
and you know it's,
it's beautiful on the screen
but it looks like a bundle where
sort of nothing is going on
and your work really was,
and your lecture describing that work
is was kind of unbelievable for a person
who's not a scientist like myself
to see this intricate machine
that lies hidden there.
- Yes, it's amazing!
- Yeah.
- It's truly amazing,
but you have to realize
that this the result of
almost 40 years of work.
And working with over
50 talented post docs
and 40 talented graduate
students who are phenomenal.
You know we work in the lab as a team,
and we share ideas and
thoughts constantly.
For example in our lab, every Tuesday
we sit for two hours,
the entire interdisciplinary
lab, all 22 of us.
There are people in the lab
who are getting their degrees
in physics, in chemistry,
in genetics, in biochemistry
and we talk and we think.
One person presents their work,
and they have to make sure
that everyone sitting there
understands their language,
and then we tackle a problem
and we troubleshoot this problem
so the work that has come
out is the cumulative output
of almost generations of
incredibly talented young people.
- Help us understand the creative moment,
maybe a creative moment that
was very important for you
and your reaction as
you realize what you've come upon,
you and your team have come upon.
- Well let me give you an example okay?
I could give you many,
but I'll give you one.
So it's known, it was always known,
that the bacterial cell
has free floating DNA
and you know the bacterial
cell is very little,
but the DNA if it's stretched out
is 1,000 times longer than the cell.
So it's compacted inside this cell,
and it was always thought
that it was sort of smunched together
like a ball of spaghetti into the cell.
That when it duplicated,
it somehow got copied,
attached to the inside of
the bacterial cell wall,
and as the cell grew it
pulled it apart all right?
To me this seemed not logical.
It wasn't, it wasn't what nature would do.
It was not clean, and we knew that
while the cell has to
duplicate this mess of DNA,
it also has to transfer
the information in it,
so you have to copy out the messages
that are encoded in this thing.
So so much is going on it cannot be
a random stochastic process.
And so we all sat and
thought about it a lot,
and we show that at least
one part of the chromosome
was attached to one pole of the cell,
and the other part of the
chromosome at the other pole,
and then we said well, can
we design an experiment
in which we put a fluorescent tag
on many many many different genetic loci
all around the chromosome?
And followed it by doing very
very sophisticated microscopy.
So we all got together and worked on this
and we realized that it would
take 10 students 50 years
sitting in the dark room
to take pictures constantly
of these fluorescent signals,
but if we automated this and
if we designed a microscope
and a computerized system that
could analyze the data for us
we could tag up in each of
you know 115 different cells,
tag a different spot on the chromosome
and then have computerated technology
solve the whole thing it would work.
And we did just this, and
what it did in one experiment
was get rid of this fog of what
people thought was going on,
showed it was completely wrong.
That the chromosome in
fact is highly organized.
You know where a gene is on the chromosome
reflects where it sits in the cell,
and that when you start
copying this chromosome
as you copy a region, it
jumps to its correct place.
So in one experiment, we
were able to truly understand
something that had been
guessed at for years and years,
and that is an incredible experience.
- And what, as this happens
is it it's an awe I guess
that just sort of drives you
to want to find another--
- Oh absolutely, so look.
Most of a scientific career is tedium,
a lot of being anxious,
a lot of thinking, a lot of dead ends,
a lot of blind alleys, and periodically
there's that wonderful moment
when you see something clearly
and you know it's true.
And we all have this.
There are not a lot of those,
but they're so wonderful
that it feeds this passion
and you want more and more of it,
and for us we just kept
digging deeper and deeper
into understanding this wonderful
machine that we call life
and it's just been very exciting.
- Now this part of your work
has a beauty, a quietness mixed
with anxiety you just said,
but you focused on bacteria,
and bacteria has led you to
also focus beyond your science
onto some big issues of public policy
because in this new
century we're in a world
where things like bioterrorism,
the failure of antibiotics,
the fact that bacteria
are as you say, engineers themselves
are all coming together to complete,
to give us a complex set of problems
that are really quite difficult.
And you're worried about that.
- Yes I think that what started me on this
is that I felt that there
had to be an informed public.
I think that decisions were being made
or not made at all about
issues that impacted our lives.
The lives of our children, the
lives of our grandchildren,
and it was very important
to me to do two things.
To number one, understand deeply
what was happening, and what could be done
and number two convey this to the public.
And by the public I mean
not only the lay people
who were interested in what's going on,
but people in government.
People in the pharmaceutical industry.
So I began being on boards
of biotechs and pharmaceutical houses
advising the government
and reading and learning
as much as I could,
and for many years, I
worked very hard to learn
how to speak to an intelligent
lay public in English
about complicated subjects.
And what worried me most was my view
that we were entering what
I call the perfect storm.
And the perfect storm being
increasing appearance of
a new infectious diseases
and old pathogens in new places.
- [Harry] Such as SARS or--
- Such as West Nile Virus, such as Ebola,
such as SARS, such as AIDS.
Lots.
And we as citizens of the United States
had to realize that we were
now part of a global community
and that we are no longer
just protecting our borders.
We live on one globe,
and there are no borders.
Someone can be in Kenya one
day and Chicago the next,
and drug resistant bugs and diseases
travel 24 hours anywhere.
So we have this instance where we have
increasing infectious
disease on the one hand.
On the other hand, we have
increasing resistance to our drugs.
Increasing resistance
to our antibacterials,
which are called antibiotics,
and to our antivirals like
Tamiflu for influenza,
and number one we have to
understand this resistance.
Number two we have to
know how to get around it,
and we have to alter our
healthcare system to deal with that.
So that's another part
of the perfect storm.
Then there's the part of the perfect storm
where it isn't financially appealing
to design new antibiotics
because if you get a new
one, it's going to be
put on the shelf and saved until
the other ones stop working
and then it has a lifetime.
It doesn't go on forever
because resistance is going to occur.
So that the profit motive
in antibiotics is not terribly high,
so now that has been left to biotechs
and we're doing it,
but to me it's probably one of
the most important things we do.
Now at the same time that
all of this is going on,
we had 2001 and the anthrax scare,
and there have been blips of bioterrorism
happening through time you know
from throwing putrefied corpses
over the walls of old castles
to measles infected blankets to Indians,
this is not brand new.
I mean this has been done for centuries,
but it does appear in our lifetime.
We have to know about it.
Fortunately the preparative
work that must be done
for both the problem of natural
infectious diseases emerging
and bioterrorism is the same.
You have to be able to
identify your pathogen,
you have to be able to
have an antidote to that,
and you must understand
the laws of quarantine
which we do a very bad job on.
- Now I want to break this apart
and pick out some of the key points here
and one is the bacteria that you know
will be the focus of our attention
in what we've been talking about,
they are very smart creatures basically.
So and you say that in a way
they're very good biological engineers.
So they're at work as
we're creating a new world.
- So I think that when we talk
about how smart the bugs are,
I think we have to understand
what I mean by that.
Bugs are smart because
they've been going through
billions of years of evolution.
They duplicate very
rapidly, under an hour.
Sometimes under a half an hour,
making a whole new set of bugs.
And they have the ability to design
new ways of getting around
problems constantly.
So if you look at the
evolution of mammals and humans
and you look at the evolution
of these little tiny bugs
that are reproducing constantly,
you can just speed up evolution
and because of that, they can design
all kinds of new ways
of doing things so that
they have figured out ways
of dealing with antibiotics
so that they design a mechanism
to not let the antibiotic in
or to let it in, but then spit it out.
Or to let it in and then
modify it chemically,
and their bag of tricks is truly amazing.
- And meanwhile they're
dealing with an adversary, us,
that is both abusing the use
of antibiotics as we give it
to more and more animals for consumption
on the one hand, but
then on the other hand
we're over using them in
the treatment of illnesses
that may not even be caused by bacteria.
- That's true, and so I think that
it's a wake up call.
It's really a wake up call.
We do have many antibiotics
that are still functioning,
but there are many pathogens that are
resistant to all of them, so
it's become absolutely critical
that we now really rein
in our use of antibiotics
for our livestock, for
our plants in orchards,
for humans and make sure that we
use them appropriately and carefully.
And this is a big problem
because it crosses
all kinds of political
and legal boundaries.
And I think that people are
beginning to deal with it, but not enough.
- And when you get into
the world of bioterrorism,
and you've said something very
important for our audience,
namely that if we deal with
this biological problem
that smart bacteria are abusive
of antibodies, antibiotics
on the one hand, that you
still have the problem
that these two worlds,
bioterrorism on the one hand,
the real threat that's
emerging biologically
they get intermingled and so sometimes
we say there's a threat from
bioterrorism, but there isn't
but what you're trying
to emphasize is that
if we deal with one we
also deal with the other.
- Absolutely, and also we have
to be cognizant of the fact
of very minor bioterrorism effect, attack.
Let's say anthrax, and bioterrorism
can come from anywhere,
inside or outside the country.
Will cause an enormous fear response,
have an enormous economic impact.
Look what happened with SARS, all right?
SARS really did not kill a lot of people.
It was not huge, but the
fear impact was huge.
And there was a major worldwide
economic disruption as a result of that.
So that if a relatively
minor quote unquote attack,
this happened to be
natural, not malevolent,
would cause such havoc
then it doesn't take much
to do something that is very worrisome,
and not on a grand scale.
- Now what would you like to see happen
you know looking into the future
in dealing with this set of problems?
Because you're dealing
with making people afraid,
which can have negative consequences,
but on the other hand you
do want to educate them.
I think you said in something
where I read Clorox is
something that everybody has
in their home that can be used yeah--
- So I think that this can be
done on a number of levels.
Number one, an educated
public is the most important.
An educated public is less
fearsome than one that's not.
And I think that we as
scientists have a responsibility
to speak as frequently and
as carefully to the public
as we possibly can about what we know,
and not put it in terms of being terrified
but rather this is what we can do.
So we can start with us in our homes
knowing how to protect ourselves.
Knowing that we should have Clorox around
if we want to clean surfaces.
That we should wash
our hands all the time.
That if there is some sort of epidemic,
a flu or something else, simple
face masks work very well
which they do in Asia all the time.
That's home.
Stay out of crowds.
But more than that, the next level
is our physicians and our hospitals.
Hospital acquired infections are huge,
and in Sweden they learned
how to deal with this
by instituting very rigorous
standards of cleanliness.
Constantly cleaning your
hands, being very diligent
about not going from one patient
to another with dirty hands.
And you know antibiotics
through this generation of ours
has made us feel sort of well,
we can always take a pill
and we'll be fine.
Well those pills are going away,
and so we have to go back to the time
of careful, careful hygiene.
And now this is happening again,
and American hospitals are just beginning
to realize my god, we've got a problem.
And they're dealing with it by instituting
very very careful regimes
of cleanliness again.
So that's another level.
Then you move from that level
to the government level,
and there you say well,
we have to have more research going on
for antibiotic discovery.
We need more research to
find out why these things,
why these pathogens
are becoming resistant.
To do that, we need oversight
and cognizance of the problem
at the government level.
So money can be put
into that as a priority,
and of course that is somewhat
happening, but not enough
and it's important to have
an administration in place
that appreciates science--
- And basic research.
- Yes, and realize that it's not just
oh this is what I do for a
living, give me more money.
It's much deeper than
that, and that in many ways
we're working for the common good.
And we have to have a political system
that can intelligently respond
to what scientists are trying to say,
whether it's world health,
whether it's climate, whether
it's energy, any of these
and there are arguments on both
sides in all of these things
but with respect to health,
and antibiotic resistance
and emerging infectious
diseases, this is not a polemic.
This is a problem here and now.
You know the canaries are dropping dead.
(laughing)
- And more than one, yeah.
- And yeah, and it's become
really critical that we do something.
- How do we deal with the conundrum
that when you put all this together,
you get a policy maker, let's
say the former vice president
who focuses on one problem, you know,
to the detriment of what the
scientific community might say
oh no this is where we need to go.
There's a threat from smallpox,
we understand that and so on
but we really need to
unlock these secrets.
And then we have the individual
scientists like yourself
whose whole creativity lies in your
ability to see things in a way
out of where science may be going
and look at it from an
entirely different perspective.
It's a lot to put together.
- Yeah, no but I think
that what you're saying
is that our political system
must have people in it who can integrate
across many different problems.
We always have many many problems
happening simultaneously.
It's a matter of priorities.
It's a matter of deciding
what's good for your country,
because that's what the
political system is doing.
It's taking care of our country,
and different people have
different thoughts as to what,
where to place problems
on the priority list,
and my belief is that what
we as scientists can do,
scientists and technologists
in many different areas,
is at least provide information.
Now we can provide all the
information that's possible,
but it has to enter a receptive ear,
and somehow we as a country
have to understand and
prioritize problems,
and I'm not gonna enter
this political fray.
I can only speak as one humble scientist
knowing that we have a problem,
and doing the best I can to approach this,
and in addition to speaking to people,
advising the government which I have done.
At the same time I
decided that I could take
my knowledge base and
design new antibiotics.
So to do that I hooked up with a chemist,
a wonderful chemist at Penn
State named Steve Benkovic,
and we designed a whole new
library of potential antibiotics
and we built a small biotech
company out here in California
and we have designed the first
new antifungal in 25 years.
Company's called Anacor,
Anacor Pharmaceuticals
and two very early stage antibiotics,
but I think that's our responsibility
to not only have the wonderful freedom
to muck around the insides of cells
and figure out how they work,
but to actually take our
knowledge and apply it
so that we can in fact help humanity,
and to me that is a very
important thing in one's life.
- Sounds very important,
and I'm just curious
what do you see as the next
place for scientists to look?
I mean what is down the road?
A puzzle that you would like to open up?
- Well I think that...
There are two things.
For me, and I'll go
down the road in my area
and in my field.
Energy.
How to create new energy
using the algorithms
and the ideas and designs
that living systems use.
To try to do that, there's this new field
called synthetic biology.
And what does that mean?
It means taking ways of doing things
from one little bug or one organism,
and putting it in another
one so that you could
for example break down
cellulose and make fuel.
Now, that sounds pretty
simplistic, and it is,
and the problem is you
can't just move some genes
from one thing to another,
even though you know
it can do it, possibly.
What you have to understand,
and what our own work has shown
is that there is a very complex
genetic network, a circuitry
of feedback loops and
regulatory mechanisms
that must be understood as
little functional modules.
So you can't expect just to
take a bunch of genes from here
and put it into another
organism to give you biofuels,
and expect it to boot up.
It's not gonna boot up,
'cause you have to understand
the intricate ways in which
all these functions
interact with one another.
And to me, the future is helping us
take lessons from the natural world.
Understand enough about
the exquisite complexity
that goes on even in the
simplest living creature,
and take a lesson from that and say
oh my goodness that's how it works!
And then we can build that,
and that's synthetic biology
so I do believe that that is a frontier.
- And you said a second one?
Was there a second one,
or it was just that one?
- Well that's the one I'm
very excited about right now.
The second of course, and is not my field,
is neural networks.
Understanding how the brain works.
Using our brains to
think about how we work.
And again, it's of incredible complexity,
but you take a complex program
and you break it down
into its individual parts
and you figure out how it works,
and to me the most beautiful
thing possibly in my life
is uncovering and learning about
how these quote unquote
simple organisms actually work.
It's staggeringly beautiful.
- One final question
requiring a brief answer,
how would you advise students
who are excited by what you've just said?
How should they prepare for
a future in these fields,
and what should they do besides
going to art school or music school?
(laughing)
- Look I think that
some of it takes a lot of
just plain hard elbow grease
as I did in my first
year in graduate school.
Take courses in the analytical sciences.
Take math, take calculus.
Understand chemistry and physics.
Biology is now, in my view,
the chemistry and physics
of a living thing.
And try to work so that
you're not afraid to approach any problem,
and you know sometimes
I feel like I'm sitting
at the bottom of Mt.
Everest and oh my god,
how am I ever gonna learn all that stuff
so I can apply this or that technology
to the question I want to answer?
Well take it in little packets.
Learn how to do one thing,
apply it to something else.
Learn how to do that, apply
that to something else,
and another important thing
that we haven't spoken about
is having mentors as
you move through life.
Having, Ted Shedlovsky
was an incredible mentor.
I never would be here today
if it weren't for him.
A wonderful scientist
named Barbara McClintock
when I was a young graduate student
had a major impact on my life.
Just by talking to these people,
understanding how they work,
understanding what their life was like.
You know many young women say
oh how can I have a life of a scientist
and still be a mother
and you know a real
person in many aspects.
- [Harry] And you've done it!
- And you can do it.
- Yeah.
- I'm not saying it's easy, but you know?
Nothing in life that's
really worth it is easy.
- On that note, Dr. Shapiro
I want to thank you very much
for being on the campus and
for appearing on our program.
- It's been a pleasure.
- Thank you, and thank you very much
for joining us for this
Conversation with History.
(pleasant synth music)